I'll sum up some of the major concepts we've covered. First of all WebGL and
THREE.JS matrices are in column order. With column order matrices we record the
transforms to the object from right to left. We apply the frame of reference
from left to right. Matrices themselves are associative. You can multiply
whichever two neighboring matrices you want in whatever order you want. Finally
matrices are not commutative. That means matrix ordered does matter. Well I
should say matrix order usually matters. Sometimes for example if you have a
series of translations in a row you can do the translations in any order. Now
that you know a lot about transforms I recommend poking around in documentation
and reading through all functions available for vectors and matrices. More
important still go and try them out. Take a three.js program of any sort and
mess with it. Change things and see what happens. Having java script, an
interpretive language with a built in debugger makes it easy to dig in and see
what all sorts of programs are doing.